[Music]  it's time for et's social study here's  what the stars are posting online  julianne hough is diving headfirst into  2017 it just felt like a good time  Dancing with the Stars judge shared this  snapshot bungee jumping in Africa quote  if I'm scared to do something it means I  have to do it well you're braver than us  girl speaking of brave Carrie  Underwood's club was recently paralyzed  from a herniated disk the little ace is  on the road to recovery as you can tell  from this friggin adorable video she  shared meanwhile MSNBC tweeted Greta Van  Susteren will join the network to host  for the record beginning Monday January  9th the veteran broadcaster told fans on  Facebook get ready you're about to join  me on an adventure  and finally supermodel sisters Gigi and  Bella Hadid are the new faces of  mosquitoes spring summer 2017 campaign  designer Jeremy Scott shared the images  on Instagram  [Music]